there is a particular
possible catalyst in this time we live
in
which is uh for really kind of raising
the question of gain of function
research for the application of virus
making viruses more dangerous
is the question of whether kovid
leaked from a lab sort of
not even answering that question but
even asking that question
is a very it seems like a very important
question to ask to uh catalyze the
conversation about the whether we should
be doing
gain of function research i mean from a
high level
uh why do you think people
even colleagues of mine are not
comfortable asking that question
and two do you think that the answer
could be that it did
leak from a lab i i think the mere
possibility
that it did leak from a lab is
evidence enough again for the
hypothetical rational national leaders
watching this simple powerpoint
if you could put the possibility at one
percent
and you look at the unbelievable
destructive power that covet had
that should be an overwhelmingly
powerful argument for excluding it
now as to whether or not that was a leak
some very very level i don't i don't
know enough about
all of the factors in the bayesian
analysis and so forth that has gone into
people making the pro argument of that
so i don't pretend to be
an expert on that and i i don't have a
point of view i
i just don't know but what i what we can
say
is it is entirely possible for a couple
of reasons
one is that there is a bsl4 lab in wuhan
the wuhan institute of virology i
believe it's the the only bsl4 in china
i could be wrong about that but
it definitely had a history
that alarmed very sophisticated u.s
diplomats and others
who were in contact with the lab and
were aware of what it was doing
uh long before covid uh coveted
um hit the world and so there are
diplomatic cables that have been
declassified
i i believe one sophisticated scientist
or other observer said
that wiv is a ticking time bomb and
i believe it's also been pretty
reasonably established that
coronaviruses
were a topic of great interest at wiv a
sars obviously came out of china and
that's a that's a coronavirus so it
would make an enormous amount of sense
for it to be studied
there and there is so much opacity
about what happened in the early days
and weeks
after the outbreak that's basically been
imposed by the chinese government that
we just don't know so it feels like a
substantially or greater than one
percent possibility to me
looking at it from the outside and
that's something that one could imagine
now we're going to the realm of thought
experiment not
me decreeing this is what happened but
you know if they're studying coronavirus
at the
ohana institute of virology um and there
is this precedent of gain of function
research that's been done on something
that is
remarkably uncontagious to humans
whereas we know coronavirus is
contagious to humans i could definitely
and there is this global consensus you
know
certainly was the case you know two or
three years ago when this work might
have started there
seems to be this global consensus that
gain of function is fine
the u.s paused funding for a little
while but paused funding they never said
private actors couldn't do it it was
just a pause of nih funding
and then that pause was lifted so again
none of this is irrational you could
certainly see the folks at wiv saying
gain a function interesting vector
chronovice virus unlike h5n1
very contagious uh we're in a a nation
that has had
terrible run-ins with coronavirus why
don't we do a little getting function on
this
and then like all labs at all levels
one can imagine this lab leaking so it's
not an impossibility and very very
level-headed people have said that
you know who've looked at it much more
deeply do believe in that outcome
uh why is it such a threat to power
the idea that leaked from a lab why is
it so threatening i don't
maybe understand this point exactly like
is it just that as governments
and especially the chinese government is
really afraid of admitting
mistakes that everybody makes so this is
a horrible mess
like chernobyl is a good example i come
from the soviet union
i mean well major mistakes were made in
chernobyl
i would argue for a lab leak to happen
the the the scale of the mistake is much
smaller
right there the the depth and the
breadth of a rot
that in bureaucracy that led to
chernobyl
is much bigger than anything that could
lead to
a lab leak because it could literally
just be
i mean i'm sure there's security very
careful security procedures
even in level three labs but it uh
i i imagine maybe you can correct me
it's all it takes is the incompetence
of a small number of individuals or even
one one individual on a particular
a couple weeks three weeks period
as opposed to a multi-year bureaucratic
failure of the entire government right
well certainly the magnitude of mistakes
and compounding mistakes that went into
chernobyl was far far far greater
but the consequence of covet outweighs
that the consequence of chernobyl
to a tremendous degree and you know i
think that
that particularly authoritarian
governments
are unbelievably reluctant to
admit to any fallibility whatsoever
there's a
long long history of that across dozens
and dozens
of authoritarian governments and to
be transparent again this is in the
hypothetical world in which this was a
leak which
again i don't have i don't personally
have enough sophistication to have an
opinion on the
on the likelihood but in the
hypothetical world in which it was a
leak
the global reaction
and the amount of global animus
and the amount of you know
the decline in global respect that would
happen toward china because every
country suffered
massively from this unbelievable damages
in terms of human lives and economic
activity disrupted
um the world would in some way present
china with that bill
and when you take on top of that
the natural disinclination for any
authoritarian government to admit any
fallibility and tolerate the possibility
of any fallibility whatsoever
and you look at the relative opacity
even though they let a world
health organization group in you know a
couple of months ago to run around
they didn't give that hoo group anywhere
near the level of access it would be
necessary to definitively say
x happened versus y the level of opacity
that surrounds those opening weeks and
months
of covet in china we just don't know
you